ciao o meglio bella tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video è
rarissimo che io faccia un video tipo
questo è capitato pochissime volte da
quando ho aperto il canale e non è un
video di intrattenimento ragazzi oggi
volevo parlarvi ho iniziato a far video
su youtube sei anni fa da questa
cameretta che state vedendo per
l'occasione ho indossato in questo
momento una delle prime maglie che ho
indossato nei miei video sono successe
tante cose da quando ho iniziato a
registrare video in questa cameretta
partiamo da questo presupposto lighting
è morto non esiste più perché lighting
era una moda per una moda dove la gente
si sfogava perché era figu sfogarsi
andiamo a rompere le palle allo youtuber
che guadagna e fa i soldi e fa le views
e non fa un cazzo dalla mattina alla
sera
anche se in realtà non è così ora vi
dico in tutti questi anni a mele thing
non mi ha mai veramente dato fastidio
perché perché io mi relaziono poco con
la gente o questo difetto sono a sociale
anche se sono youtuber più conosciuto in
italia sono sociale perché non volevo
esserlo youtube per conosciuti in italia
cioè è successo io ho iniziato a fare
video per conto mio e non pensavo mai di
arrivare a questo punto io non ho
cercato il successo era proprio l'ultima
cosa che volevo fare
c'è 2 sentivi bambini che parlavano
quando erano piccoli dicevano che cosa
vuoi fare al calciatore a l'attore vuole
fare musicista arrivavi da me che cosa
vuoi fare
non è che non ci speravo e che proprio
non mi interessava ed è successo è
successo che ho spopolato su youtube
senza volerlo cioè nel senso io non mi
vanto di questa cosa perché a me non me
ne frega veramente un cazzo c'è per me
la fama non esiste
giuro non interessano minimamente fare
like non è il mio scopo nella vita fare
views e non lo è neanche quindi tutto
quello che che ricevo da voi sono e
affetto e vedo che i miei video vanno
tanto e quindi sono contento perché so
che quello che faccio funziona ma
finisce lì
sono state dette miliardo di cose da
quando ho iniziato a fare video di tutto
è stato detto di tutte queste cose ne
appoggio soltanto una la verità è che
non mi sono mai comprato gli iscritti la
verità è che
non è vero che non mi merito quello che
ho secondo me nella più totale onestà ve
lo dico i miei video richiedono lavoro
molto più di quello che una persona
possa pensare adesso ci metto molto di
meno a farli rispetto a una volta però
ci metto comunque del tempo
la cosa sulla quale io tra tutte le cose
che si sono dette posso dare ragione e
sul fatto che io guadagno di più di un
carabiniere che rischia la vita ogni
giorno questo su questo io non posso
dire niente non c'è niente che io possa
dire in contrario è assolutamente vero
resta il fatto che io non ho colpa di
questo nel senso che il sistema non lo
decido io
il sistema che fa sì che i calciatori
siano pagati milioni di euro l'anno
sistema che decide che gli attori
vengano pagati in sacco che musicisti
vengono pagati un sacco youtuber non
verranno mai pagati come questi ultimi
come i cacciatori come gli attori
musicisti ma vengono pagati bene
sicuramente molto di più di un
carabiniere
questa cosa è sbagliata resta il fatto
che quello che faccio non è niente di
negativo
io non sto rubando a nessuno io che cosa
faccio io faccio video su dei
videogiochi che trovo su internet faccin
trattenimento per mezzo dei videogiochi
quindi io non sono neanche un gamer
io sono un intrattenitore più che gamer
gamer non mi definisco neanche ma in
tutto quello che faccio in tutto quello
che vedete sul mio canale cede il lavoro
è molto di più di quello che possiate
pensare non mi riferisco solo al cercare
il videogioco registrarlo che ci si
mette alle volte ore montarlo che ci si
mette più che registra lo farà la
copertina a scegliere il titolo
possibilmente click bait c'è un sacco di
roba dietro youtube molto di più di
quello che possiate pensare poi ci sono
i network c'è i copti non c'è un sacco
di gemalto di più di quanto possiate
pensare quindi per me lo youtube è
veramente un lavoro e non lo sto dicendo
per difendere la mia posizione lo direi
anche se sapessi come stanno le cose e
se io non fossi know you tube
vi dico io l'ho youtuber lo facevo anche
quando andavo a scuola ho continuato a
fare lo youtuber fino alla quinta
superiore senza prendere niente senza
prendere lo stipendio perché per me non
era un lavoro all'inizio era soltanto un
hobby poi dalla quinta superiore in poi
è iniziato a diventare anche un lavoro
nonostante questo non ho mai voluto
lasciare gli studi dovevo si affari
video che studiare quindi dormivo
veramente tre ore a notte
e via per tutto per tutta la quinta
superiore maturità compresa e in quel
periodo ero anche fidanzato quindi era
casino incredibile e della cosa che vi
ricordo sempre ragazzi non mollate mai
gli studi rifinite la scuola in tutto e
per tutto io non ho mollato anche se per
me era già un lavoro io potevo già fare
questo ma non me ne fregava niente la
scuola era importante poi sono uscito mi
hanno anche dato un calcio in culo per
come sono uscito ma non importa va bene
così quindi a tutte le persone che
vogliono fare youtubers tutti quelli che
vogliono intraprendere questa strada la
prima cosa che dovete sapere e che non
dovete farlo per raggiungere un
obiettivo della serie dovete avere
successo perché io li ho io di obiettivi
non ne avevo non ne avevo neanche mezzo
non me ne fregava neanche niente e sono
arrivato qua senza motivazioni solo
facendo quello che mi piaceva perché mi
divertivo quindi la primissima cosa che
vi dovete divertire
se mai dovesse iniziare a prendere piede
quello che state facendo ma non solo
nell'ambito di youtube anche nell'ambito
musicale se diventati senza da diventare
conosciuti o nell'ambito dello sport si
è diventati calciatori conosciuti
ragazzi non mollate gli studi finite
quello che avete iniziato sempre finite
sempre piuttosto dormite meno fate uno
sforzo ma finite quello che avete
iniziato siamo andati un po topi che
rispetto a quello che stavo dicendo
comunque torniamo sul discorso
principale quando ho iniziato ad avere
successo poi sono iniziati anche i
commenti negativi commenti che non ho
mai calcolato l thing è morto veramente
morto
la prima moda delle thing è stata il
dare del raccomandato alle persone mi si
dava del raccomandato perché si diceva
che io compravo gli iscritti cosa che
non era vera però vabbè andava di moda
dire che quella persona era raccomandata
quindi va poi andata di moda la parola
cancro quindi si dava del cancro a caso
è infatti è quello che ironizzo e
mettersi in italia l'ultima cosa prima
della morte delle thing è stato il
venduto con quanta superficialità però
dai del venduto ad una persona quando
una persona fa intrattenimento e normale
che degli sponsor la chiamino per fare
dei placement mettiamola così per
promuovere dei prodotti è normalissimo
come vedete adesso non faccio nomi di
brand ma ultimamente io ne ho fatti di
placement e non c'è niente di male anzi
oltre che essere lavoro è motivo di
orgoglio perché vuol dire che un brand
che si lega a me
un brand che ci crede e io sono
pienamente soddisfatto di questo quindi
per me orgoglio oltre questo quante cose
non sapete
parlo per me quindi solo ed
esclusivamente per fa vj però io ricevo
tante proposte al giorno e non le
accetto mica tutte c'è nel senso non è
che ogni volta che vedete un placement
vuol dire che quando mi è arrivata con
la proposta che ho detto sì va bene lo
faccio perché se arriva un azienda che
vuole promuovere del sugo in scatola e
mi dice fa vj fai il placement al sugo
in scatola gli dico anche va tra piante
perché io che cosa strani kia centro con
il suo ben scatola non c'entro niente se
lisciani mi chiede di fare lo sponsor al
al suo tablet dico wow mi chiama che
figata incredibile io sono lusingato di
questo ci mancherebbe per me dare del
venduto ad una persona è sintomo di
immaturità non che io mi sia mai offeso
anche perché non troppa gente mi ha mai
dato del venduto danno del venduto a
molte altre persone in realtà però la
prova vendute proprio è stata l'ultima
arma degli haters prima di scomparire e
non aveva senso perché comunque sia tu
del venduto lo dà in una persona ma per
quale motivo scusami se una premium
brand di contatta perché vuole fare un
lavoro perché dovresti dire di no se è
un bel lavoro quindi in sintesi in tutto
questo in tutto questo discorso non c'è
mai stato niente di male in quello che
faccio non c'è niente di male se io
faccio dei placement e non c'è niente di
male se il mio hobby è diventato un
lavoro questo lo dico per quelli che in
tutto questo tempo hanno spalato merda a
caso che non mi hanno realmente ferito
perché se mi avessero ferito io questo
video l'avrei fatto molto prima
l'avrei avrei dato queste spiegazioni
quando aveva senso darle adesso non ha
quasi più senso darle perché lighting è
morto quindi potrei lasciare tutto
correre sticazzi molte volte la gente mi
diceva nei commenti fa vj non dargli
retta non ascoltarli ma in realtà non ce
n'era bisogno c non avevo bisogno di
essere difeso da nessuno io vi ringrazio
per averlo fatto se l'avete fatto perché
l'avete fatto per per essere gentili
miei confronti e vi ringrazio ma in
realtà non ce n'era bisogno c'è
veramente io non mi sono mai sentito
offeso se qualcuno mi ha dato del cancro
del venduto del qualsiasi cosa perché
non mi importa del parere delle persone
che non conosco quindi non mi interessa
mi faccia molto più male se un mio amico
mi diceva fai schifo
cosa che non è mai successa perché le
persone che mi stanno accanto grazie a
dio mi vogliono bene
in tutto questo casino per concludere
tutto quanto c'è solo un
la cosa che vorrei precisare che
gradirei che venisse precisata l'unica
le thing in tutto il suo percorso dalla
fonte nato a quando è morto ha tirato
fuori un argomento che è quello del
fatto che io ho degli iscritti bambini
anche se fosse così non sarebbe un
problema per me perché farei esattamente
le stesse cose che faccio quindi se
fosse così direi sti cazzi il fatto è
uno la verità è che io ho 4 milioni di
iscritti perché il mio target di età va
dai sei sette otto anni non lo so dal
molto basso fino a finire ai quasi 30
anni qui ai 20 c 25 poi dai 25 ai 30
molto meno profine 25 perché nel web si
è diffusa negli ultimi anni la diceria
che io ho solo iscritti i bambini perchè
si è diffusa questa diceria perché nei
commenti dei miei video nei commenti
delle mie foto e negli eventi che faccio
si presentano molti bambini e poi
ragazzini dunque minorenni non di
vent'anni ma questo perché perché un
bambino un ragazzino è molto più
partecipe nella vita di uno youtuber o
di un cantante un adulto invece no io
seguo pd poi da sette anni ho iniziato a
seguirlo che ero quasi maggiorenne
sapete quanti commenti ho lasciato sotto
i video dp di paris neanche uno perché
sono grande abbastanza da dire vabbè lo
seguo mi diverto finisce il video e stop
che è quello che fanno gli adulti quando
un adulto secondo mio video un adulto
parlo anche di quello che a 18 anni un
maggiorenne guarda il mio video si
diverte e la roba finisce lì ma non
vengono i miei eventi non mi commentano
le foto si limitano seguirmi e basta
tutte le persone che stanno guardando
questo video che avete dai 18 anni in su
che siete un buon 30 quasi 40 per cento
e non ci credereste mai ma è così non
siete i soli la maggioranza sono
sicuramente minorenni
ma è proprio per questo che io ho
tantissimi iscritti perché il mio target
è molto ampio io vado a prendere sia il
target più piccolo sia il target più
grande ed è per questo che faccio sia
lisciani che hp come sponsor
ok ed è una cosa che nel tempo la gente
o il meglio i più grandi non hanno
capito nel senso che mi vengono tutti a
dire quando mi fermano per strada
migliore lo giuro ogni volta che che
vado in giro la scena è sempre sempre
sempre la stessa quando mi fermo al
ragazzino mi dice famiglia e famiglie le
faccio una foto io certo non ci
mancherebbe quando mi ferma quello
grande e l'adulto mi dice fa vj grande
lo sai che ti segue o vent'anni
e poi c'è questa pausa dove lui si
aspetta che io acconsente di ko mi segue
sei grande e data lui non lo sa ma 100
metri prima mi ha fermato un ragazzo e
mi ha detto ciò va vj io ti seguo io ho
25 anni e anche lui è rimasto fermo così
ad aspettare la mia reaction ed è sam è
sempre così c'è sempre questa pausa dio
mio ed è questo che mi dà fastidio mi ha
dato fastidio il fatto che si sia sparsa
questa voce che io ho solo iscritti i
bambini tanto da convincere tutti che
sia così anche se in realtà non è così
tanto che gli adulti quando mi fermano
si sentono tutti in dovere di di
sentirsi gli unici a seguirmi ma non è
così siete il 40 per cento degli
iscritti ad essere adulti e non ve lo
dicono solo le mie statistiche di st lo
dico io quando mi fermate
io sono super contento di fare una foto
con voi quello che volete scambiare due
parole sono veramente la persona più
tranquilla del mondo e non ho io è tra
l'altro faccio questo faccio anche
questa premessa non ho fatto questo
discorso perché mi voglio vantare di
avere iscritti sia grandi che piccoli
non me ne frega una sega ve lo sto
dicendo perché voglio evitare che la
gente quando mi fermi passava da mi
guardi mi dica geova vj o vent'anni
voglio evitare questa pausa vi prego non
basta non ne posso più
quindi allora io ve lo giuro ho tentato
in tutti i modi possibili di rendere
questo video corto perché ho fatto
questo video vi ho parlato di tutto
quello che è stato il negativo
esorcizzandolo in modo tale che tutti
quanti abbiate chiara la situazione di
dickie e micky sono di chi state
seguendo non c'è nient'altro che io
debba dire che lory aver detto tutto
adesso io ho parlato solo ed
esclusivamente delle
negativo di tutto quello di cui non ho
mai parlato nel dettaglio è uscito fuori
un video spero che non sia noioso robe
del genere non sto qua dirvi che potrei
fare 20 video per parlarvi di tutte le
cose positive invece che ci sono stati
che ogni mille persone che mi danno
affetto c'era un nate era ai tempi
adesso non c'è neanche più quello però
quando c'erano gli hater era uno su
mille ma uno su cento da ieri ho
ricevuto un affetto incredibile quindi
prendete tutto lighting trasformatelo
impositivo e moltiplicate per cento ed è
quello che ha decorato la mia vita negli
ultimi anni il vostro affetto e stato
importantissimo l'affetto che mi
dimostrate ai raduni quando mi scrivete
quando mi lasciati commenti grandi o
piccoli che siate non me ne frega un
cazzo di quanti anni avete il solo fatto
che mi dimostrate affetto per me vale
tantissimo come persona vale più di
poter andare in giro a dire o 4 milioni
di iscritti non me ne frega na sega di
avere 4 milioni d'iscritti mi frega
riavere le persone che mi vogliono bene
sembra così scontato come discorso
sembra anche quasi un disco solo a
leccaculo ma non ho bisogno di recare il
culo a nessuno perché io questo video
potevo tranquillamente non farlo l'ho
fatto semplicemente per dirvi cosa
realmente penso qual è la verità qual è
stata la verità in tutti questi anni
cosa che molto probabilmente voi
sapevate già però ci tenevo a dirvelo io
di persona perché non ho mai fatto un
video dedicato a questa cosa senza di
voi mio canale non esisterebbe senza di
voi non avere mai viaggiato per il mondo
non avrei mai arricchito quella che è la
mia cultura il mio modo di essere io
sono cambiato tantissimo da quando ho
iniziato a fare video sono cambiato di
brutto voi mi avete cambiato la vita
ragazze non vi parlo solo del mio lavoro
non è per quello che guadagno il
guadagno è inferiore al al valore
aggiuntivo che avete dato che avete dato
le mie giornate ve lo giuro ha tutto
quello che posso fare è cercare di farvi
sorridere il più possibile con i miei
video non con questo perché questo era
l'unico video serio mannaggia a me però
con tutti i video che farò è che ho
fatto che farò ancora
spero di divertirmi il più possibile
questo è tutto ciò che posso fare per
tentare di ricambiare in qualche modo il
favore che voi avete fatto a me madonna
ha fatto registra 4 devo montare ma li
mortacci di youtubers in conclusione io
non volevo lasciare niente di negativo
io da questo video nei commenti non
vogliono
della serie valigie non ti preoccupare
fa vj non perché non mi sono mai
preoccupato di niente anche quando
lighting c'era avevate diritto ad un
video dove io spiegavo tutto quello che
per me era youtube tutto quello che io
sono credo di aver risposto a quasi
tutte le domande che mi erano state
poste negli ultimi quattro anni quindi
ragazzi spero di non avervi annoiato
troppo però che questo video vi sia
piaciuto invece momento è un mi piace
anche avere i social che come noi è
ridotto tenere scrizione se non siete
ancora i siti iscrivetevi e noi ci
rivediamo in un prossimo video mi
dispiace che non ho il telecomando però
lo ha lasciato a milano però la vecchia
felpa varrà pure qualcosa mela ragazzi